[Musique]
on en sait encore peu sur l'auteur du
drame cette semaine à Amqui mais le
Premier ministre nous a invité à
intervenir quand un proche ne va pas
bien mais des fois c'est pas simple
[Musique]
j'avais comme des amis imaginaires puis
je pensais que ses amis là ils avaient
été attaqués agressé par des gens
sa famille on
va entre les droits la psychiatre et
notre sécurité à tous la schizophrénie
c'est
cette maladie terrible il a fallu un
événement grave après des années à se
battre pour qu'on le soigne c'est pas
toujours facile d'évaluer la dangerosité
d'une personne qui souffre de maladies
mentales souvent ce sont les proches qui
sont le mieux placées mais comment
sont-ils traités par le système personne
voulait nous entendre non c'est pas nous
mais ça doit être la justice c'est pas
la justice ça doit être l'hôpital c'est
pas l'hôpital ça va être les suce nous
on s'est senti vraiment un puissant puis
en même temps incompris parce que nous
on est ses parents ici marie-more Denis
bienvenue à enquête
je trouve ça triste que ce que je
l'aurais fait
ce qui s'est passé et c'est des choses
qui sont irréversibles
c'est déjà ce qu'ils auraient pu être
évident parce que ça veut dire qu'il y a
eu un manquement quelque part il y avait
des signes précurseurs qui montraient
qu'il y avait sur moi quelque chose qui
allait se passer
[Musique]
Frédéric j'ai accusé de deux meurtres
préméditées
sévère qui est réfractaire au traitement
frais d'avoir les événements étaient les
salles lui-même Jean-Philippe Blais 29
ans a formellement été accusé du meurtre
de sa mère Jean-Luc Fernand 32 ans
aurait tué sa mère Suzanne Desjardins ce
serait rendu au poste de police pour
forcer son fils à subir une évaluation
psychiatrique à Québec les parents d'un
homme de 30 ans accusé du meurtre d'un
voisin lance un cri du coeur ils avaient
pourtant alerté les autorités avant le
drame n'aurait jamais dû arriver tout
était en place pour l'éviter
l'histoire se répète année après année
des crimes graves commis par des gens
qui souffrent de troubles mentaux
sévères des drames qu'on n'arrive pas à
empêcher même si plusieurs les avaient
vu venir des gens imprévisibles au
parcours pourtant prévisible
[Musique]
ils sont commencé par le début moi
j'aimerais ça que vous me parliez un
petit peu de l'histoire de Joshua
comment il était quand il était petit
quand il était bébé
son petit visage en sortant
[Musique]
de la Boîte à Surprise coucou je suis là
rock côté et Polina machhallah se sont
rencontrés au Congo il y a presque 30
ans ils se sont mariés et ensemble ils
ont eu cinq enfants quatre filles et un
seul garçon Joshua c'est le deuxième
enfant du couple il a aujourd'hui 25 ans
[Musique]
il réussissait très bien à l'école au
sport il était faisait presque tout le
sport
rien ne laissait croire qu'un jour
Joshua allait sombrer dans la maladie
mentale au point où il allait commettre
un crime très grave
ses parents disent avoir observé les
premiers indices de la maladie à la fin
de l'adolescence
moi je dirais dans peut-être les deux
dernières années du secondaire c'est
plus difficile un moins concentration
moins de
même sa chambre et tu rentrais dans sa
chambre tu avais envie de sortir la
rapidement parce que c'était les bordel
complet mais il était pas comme ça avant
[Musique]
le passage du secondaire au CGP est
difficile pour Joshua il commence à
sortir dans les bars à consommer de
l'alcool et de la drogue ces notes sont
ensuite libres et Joshua n'arrive pas à
garder sa place dans l'équipe de
football
plus
ancé
[Musique]
dans ses emplois il faut y penser des
jours sans se laver là parce que il
était dans dans des crises
l'envoyer là que à ce moment là il était
plus lui-même
[Musique]
je vous dirais des situations comme
celle de joshuan est malheureusement pas
rare on voit ça régulièrement des jeunes
hommes des jeunes femmes qui sont tout à
fait normal qui ont un avenir prometteur
et que tout d'un coup en fait
progressivement vont développer des
symptômes de psychose ils vont commencer
à être une différente personne plus ça
allait plus on appelait la police
ça allait pas bien moi personnellement
en arriver à demander à Joshua de
quitter à la maison
c'est
comme en quelque part j'ai échoué
[Musique]
dans le code Joshua ça va prendre
plusieurs incidents faux diagnostic
épisode de violence pour qu'on comprenne
quelques années plus tard que c'était
les premiers signes de la schizophrénie
[Musique]
du simple déprimé à celui qu'on enferme
à perpétuité un groupe étonnant c'est
l'essai dont les facultés ont résisté à
l'internement car en ces lieux depuis
des générations l'homme a vu sombrer sa
faculté d'espérer
[Musique]
jusque dans les années 70 ceux qui
avaient des comportements étranges et
dérangeants étaient vu comme des fous on
les enfermait dans des asiles et il
pouvait y rester longtemps parfois toute
leur vie
quand on regarde l'histoire la
psychiatrie légale comme un pendule qui
était beaucoup plus au niveau
paternaliste soigner tous les patients
qu'on pense qu'il y avait besoin de
soins même si des fois il y avait
certains abus
[Musique]
la tradition carcérale à la vie dure
dans cette institution où l'on a
englouti sans espoir durant un siècle
écart celles et ceux des nôtres qu'on
appelait les fous
[Applaudissements]
avec les années 60 les années 70 avec
les droits de la personne dont les
droits des personnes avec des maladies
psychiatriques on a eu le pendule qui
est allé beaucoup plus vers le droit des
patients
c'est un grand plaisir pour moi
aujourd'hui de présenter la population
du Québec cette politique de santé
mentale le processus de la
désinstitutionnalisation va se faire sur
une vingtaine d'années
tout le phénomène de la
désinstionalisation on va se faire
beaucoup plus facilement à condition
d'avoir les ressources dans la
communauté pour que ça ça marche par
exemple
[Musique]
en donnant plus de droits aux gens qui
souffrent de troubles mentaux ont leur
confie la responsabilité d'aller
chercher des soins eux-mêmes ce qui est
un problème quand la personne ne
reconnaît pas qu'elle est malade Joshua
lui était de plus en plus violent sa
famille avait peur et voulait qu'il
reçoive de l'aide
je veux juste les remettre dans chaque
le moment où il était avec nous à Noël
l'épisode dans l'escalier à l'extérieur
après ça c'était le président de là où
je me suis ramassé à l'hôpital
puis ressorti à nouveau puis là il est
rentré par infraction dans la boutique
il y a eu plusieurs événements c'est
pour ça qu'on a un peu comme de la
misère à les mettre dans l'ordre
chronologique tu peux pas faire
autrement que dans d'arriver à la
conclusion que il est malade il y a
besoin d'aide puis elle vient elle peut
pas venir de nous à part le fait qu'on
va continuer de soutenir de l'ami puis
d'aller le voir puis etc
il faut nous protéger il faut protéger
ses sœurs c'est notre fils puis tu vas
le mettre à l'hôpital psychiatrique
c'est toute une décision mais c'était
évident qu'il fallait passer par là je
choix il voyait pas les choses du tout
la même mais voyons je suis pas ma lame
puis ça ça habitait ces jours ses nuits
je suis pas malade enfin que je vais pas
rester à l'hôpital c'est déchirant pour
les familles parce que des fois ils sont
victimes d'agression puis ils voudraient
pas porter plainte qui voudraient juste
amener à l'hôpital puis qu'on le traite
c'est ça qu'on veut
au fil des ans la psychiatre Marie
Frédéric Allard a été appelé à évaluer
et à se prononcer sur l'état mental de
nombreux accusés qui se sont retrouvés
sous les projecteurs comme Lucas Rocco
magnotta et Alexandre Bissonnette
c'est dur des fois de convaincre
quelqu'un on se retrouve vers l'aspect
la voix légale qui qui marche des fois
qui marche pas des fois aussi
refuser de se faire soigner ou d'aller à
l'hôpital c'est un droit fondamental à
moins que la personne représente un
danger pour elle-même ou pour les autres
dans ce cas là il existe essentiellement
deux moyens de l'amener comme son gré à
l'hôpital la première c'est la personne
représente un danger grave et immédiat
les policiers le constatent par exemple
la personne à menace de suicider ou tuer
quelqu'un ils peuvent l'amener contre
son gré à l'hôpital l'autre option les
proches médecins intervenants peuvent se
tourner vers un juge pour demander
qu'elle soit évaluée mais il faut
toujours qu'elle la notion de danger
pour elle-même ou pour les autres donc
si le juge croit que suffisamment
d'éléments peu ordonner une évaluation
psychiatrique et si c'est le cas les
policiers n'ont pas le choix de l'année
on est allé rock et moi en cours pour
demander une ordonnance d'évaluation on
est revenu avec ça avec l'ordonnance ça
c'était si la police l'arrêtait si la
police le trouvait il devait l'arrêter
l'amener à l'hôpital mais c'était pas
facile de l'arrêter c'était pas facile
de l'amener à l'hôpital
pour moi ça a été beaucoup des idées
qu'on me suivait puis que les gens
cherchent à me faire du mal ou que les
gens qui cherchent à m'aider en fait ils
étaient contre moi
[Musique]
dans ma tête je pensais que j'avais des
ennemis qui venaient d'autres mondes et
tout ça
tout ce que je vivais c'était juste
normal
[Musique]
après la pause quand des parents vivent
dans la peur constante de ce que
pourrait faire leur enfant
il doit y aller tellement pas bien que
je me souviens j'avais dit mes fils mais
là vous bourrez vos portes de chambre
parce que je savais pas ce qui pourrait
se passer
[Musique]
on est tous bien conscients que le
risque zéro n'existe pas et que les gens
qui souffrent de troubles mentaux ont
des droits n'empêche qu'on peut
certainement se demander si on fait tout
ce qu'il faut pour éviter les drames
[Musique]
une question et sur toutes les lèvres
aujourd'hui pourquoi Abdullah shake
était-il libre
quelque part les victimes ont tout été
tuées au hasard tu peux pas pardonner ça
avec des problèmes mentaux ou quelque
chose
[Musique]
c'était l'été dernier à Montréal
dans un rayon de 3 km 3 meurtres gratuit
commis en 24 heures le principal suspect
est un jeune homme de 26 ans il est
localisé dans un hôtel et abattu par les
policiers on réalise bien que c'est un
événement isolé qui s'est produit
Montréal est toujours une ville
sécuritaire pendant que les politiciens
veulent se faire rassurant les médias
révèlent des faits de plus en plus
troublants au sujet du suspect l'auteur
présumée souffrait de troubles de santé
mentale a été connus des policiers lors
de la dernière hospitalisation
d'Abdullah chahik 26 ans son nom a été
largement diffusé mais on avait encore
jamais vu Abdullah shake enquête a
obtenu ces images où on le voit ici
enfants Abdullah chahik est né au Québec
de parents immigrants il grandit dans
une famille comme bien d'autres il a
deux frères et une sœur mais à la fin de
l'adolescence il commence à consommer de
la drogue et multiplie les délits
éventuellement il aura un diagnostic de
schizophrénie près de la personnalité
narcissique et antisocial
moi j'ai été appelé à représenter cette
personne à piedlever très peu de temps
avant l'audiance et j'ai pris
connaissance évidemment du rapport
psychiatrique
maître François Legault est avocat
depuis 40 ans et la représenté Abdullah
chaik devant la commission d'examens des
troubles mentaux pour homme effet comme
il y a quelques années et pour lequel il
a été déclaré non criminellement
responsable
l'audience a eu lieu quelques mois avant
le drame et même s'il représentait
toujours un risque important pour la
sécurité du public la commission l'a
maintenu en liberté
[Musique]
il y avait des indices qui tendaient à
démontrer qui devenait plus responsable
prenait sa médicament
il souhaitaient aller travailler il y
avait encore des problèmes de
comportement mais mais rien qui laissait
présager des gestes de violence dans ce
cas-ci
le risque était assumable qu'il puisse
être libéré mais avec des conditions
très strictes dont une délégation de
pouvoir dès le moment où une condition
n'est pas respectée le directeur de
l'hôpital doit communiquer avec les
policiers pour faire arrêter la personne
mettre le goût est aussi l'avocat de
Joshua côté mashallah
très grave de schizophrénie qui avait
été mal évalué maltraité
[Musique]
comme shake Joshua ne reconnaît pas
qu'il est malade
la requête de ses parents a été entendue
par le juge qui ordonne que Joshua soit
évalué par un psychiatre
malgré cette ordonnance difficile pour
les policiers de l'attraper et de
l'emmener à l'hôpital
[Musique]
je peux dire on a comploté
pour que parce qu'il venait ici il était
là sur le balcon régulièrement alors moi
je continue de lui parler pendant que la
police
parce que il y avait pas moyen de le de
l'arrêter la police est venue il a
arrêté devant moi ils ont menotté je
pleurais de le voir c'est fermé noter
[Musique]
donc ce sera le premier contact de
Joshua avec la psychiatrie
ses parents sont soulagés mais pas pour
longtemps ils ont été très surpris de
voir que je sois a été libéré rapidement
par le psychiatre il lui a donné des
références pour la gestion de la colère
ce qui soupçonnaient c'est un trouble de
comportement alors qu'on sait
aujourd'hui que c'était beaucoup plus
grave que ça
est évalué par deux psychiatres qui
devaient déterminer si et représentait
un danger donc pour voir ultimement si
elle allait le garder plus longtemps à
l'hôpital si vous voulez le garder plus
longtemps il aurait dû retourner devant
un jeu pour le convaincre que c'était
nécessaire et pour les aider dans leur
décision il y aurait pu appeler les
parents de chat mais les psychiatres y a
pas appelé les parents du choix
finalement
[Musique]
à peine une heure et demie après avoir
été emmené à l'hôpital par les policiers
Joshua retourne chez ses parents
une heure et demi plus tard Joshua était
ici sur le balcon
assis
on a vraiment essayé de parler avec
quelqu'un
sans même s'enquérir auprès des
personnes proches mais qu'est-ce qui se
passe le maintien à qui on a parlé les
psychiatres qui en a parlé cette journée
là il a dit que c'était nous les
problèmes
alors on peut pas faire ça maintenant
André Delorme est un psychiatre reconnu
et respecté il a été directeur national
de la santé mentale au Québec pendant 15
ans tout en continuant de pratiquer
comme psychiatre
je peux pas prendre une prise de sang ou
un rayon X qui va me permettre de dire à
votre schizophrénie est très élevé il
fait que vous êtes en crise en ce moment
je suis pas capable de mesurer rien qui
me permet de dire vous faites une
dépression vous avez une schizophrénie
vous avez une institut alors j'y vais
sur l'information et sur l'observation
j'avais une certaine affinité avec la
parole donc j'étais capable de manipuler
un peu mon chemin
faire en sorte que les choses paraissent
bien
[Musique]
donc eux ils sont un peu dépourvus parce
que ils peuvent pas rentrer dans la tête
on me l'a dit souvent je peux pas
prendre une ville puis faire un trou
dans ta tête puis voir qu'est-ce qui se
passe c'est toi qui dois m'expliquer
sinon on peut rien faire
[Musique]
est-ce que tu estimes que tu as été
relâché trop vite
réaliser que même avec ce que je leur
racontais qu'il y avait il y avait
peut-être des détails qui faisaient pas
de sens ils étaient déjà au courant de
certains gestes que j'avais combien donc
ils ont dû quand même
pousser ça un peu plus loin donc
on est allé à la rencontre d'un couple
de l'esprit qui côtoie la schizophrénie
de près
les parents qui se sentent impuissants
face au système depuis longtemps
bonjour Maxime illustrateur ça va bien
oui
ils tiennent à raconter leur histoire
mais ne veulent pas être identifié pour
ne pas nuire à leur relation avec leurs
enfants on a demandé à une illustrateur
de dessiner leur histoire pour eux tout
a basculé il y a plus de 25 ans
dont on a trois enfants puis on a nos
deux garçons qui sont atteints de
schizophrénie
il y avait rien il y avait aucun nuage à
l'horizon il y avait rien qui pouvait
nous dire c'est que
qu'on vivrait avec eux ce qu'on vit
présentement
[Musique]
un moment donné ça a explosé
comme un volcan qui entre en éruption le
tout un coup la colère est sorti il
s'est mis à crier alors qu'avant il nous
parlait pour dire ben là vous êtes des
clones toi ma mère est un clone toi mon
père était le démon partez d'ici
[Musique]
il y avait tellement pas bien que je me
souviens j'avais dit mes fils mais là
vous bourrez vos portes de chambre parce
que je savais pas ce qui pourrait se
passer
[Musique]
qu'on a appelé la police
mais là il y a pas voulu ouvrir sa porte
le policier m'a demandé est-ce qu'il y a
des arbres
il y avait deux trois épées immédiaires
parce qu'il est très fort sur le métier
Val il y avait une hache une faux fait
que
mon fils était fâché après moi parce
qu'il disait plus jamais ça parce que je
l'avais trahi j'avais appelé la police
qu'est-ce qui va se passer dans combien
de temps dans combien d'heures combien
de jours combien de semaines quand
est-ce qu'il va arriver quelque chose
mais tu sais qu'il va arriver quelque
chose
il m'a dit je me suis fait une arabe qui
rit
où je meurs où je vis
puis l'or rendu à l'hôpital les médecins
n'ont ausculté puis finalement ils m'ont
dit que c'était entré le couteau
dans le ventre à un centimètre de la
haute une coupure à laorte c'est
vraiment
[Musique]
malgré deux
rapports de psychiatre dont un de 11
pages qui concluaient qui étaient
dangereux pour le même pour les autres
les Russes faire libérer avec l'aide de
son avocat puis du jour plus tard de
laisser jeter d'un immeuble de trois
étages parce qu'il pensait qu'il était
probablement un oiseau
si on a failli perdre une deuxième fois
quand la PS4
là j'ai dit que bien regarde-moi bien
lol aussi tu donnes congés à mon fils et
qu'il se blesse ou qu'il blesse
quelqu'un parce qu'il va pas bien tu vas
m'avoir sur le dos le reste des jours
leur fils passera finalement neuf mois à
l'hôpital en psychiatrie
après la pause on accompagne une équipe
qui agit sur le terrain pour éviter que
les choses ne dérapent
l'autre m'a dit que c'est un petit peu
difficile la solitude est-ce que toi
encore ton ami elle sent ouais il y a
1000 personnes qui vivent à Montréal qui
bénéficierait d'avoir ce service là mais
qu'il l'emporte parce que il manque 10
équipes
pour ses parents c'était évident que je
choix est une bombe à retardement mais
dans le système actuel les choses ont
dérapé une victime innocente en a payé
le prix
à l'été 2018 l'état de Joshua continue
de se détériorer il entre dans la maison
familiale et il attaque son père cette
fois recruter décide de porter plainte
contre son fils Joshua fait face à des
accusations criminelles introduction par
effraction vol agression armée et voie
de fait causant des lésions corporelles
le juge ordonne une évaluation
psychiatrique
[Musique]
j'avais deux histoires qui se suivaient
je me racontais une histoire puis je la
confond avec la réalité
[Musique]
dans ma tête le monde réel et le monde
de je venais c'était une ils avaient
rentré en collision
je pensais que j'étais comme observé
encerclé
j'halluciner des créatures et ça me
forçait à poser des gestes parce que je
me sentais ainsi que en danger
les deux psychiatres de l'Institut
Philippe Pinel qui ont évalué Joshua la
demande du juge note dans le dossier
symptômes psychotique et soupçon de
schizophrénie en émergence il est
déclaré non criminellement responsable
de la série d'accusation
Joshua est détenu à l'hôpital
après sept mois d'hospitalisation son
état se stabilise même s'il refuse la
médication malgré les soupçons de
schizophrénie le psychiatre traitant de
Joshua suggère sa libération sans
condition et sans suivi psychiatrique la
Commission d'examen des troubles mentaux
se range derrière cette recommandation
et Joshua est libéré
la Commission d'examen des troubles
mentaux ne s'occupent que des dossiers
ou la personne ne représente un risque
important pour la sécurité du public si
la personne ne représente pas un risque
important à ce moment-là la Commission
doit libérer la personne sans condition
[Musique]
cette semaine en jeu comment empêcher
des personnes souffrant de maladies
mentales de commettre des meurtres
l'émission en jeu s'est penchée sur la
question en 2006 le ministère de la
Santé reconnaît qu'il y a un problème il
a déposé un nouveau plan d'action en
santé mentale le psychiatre André
Delorme et le maître d'oeuvre de cette
réforme qui prévoit mieux encadrer les
malades en multipliant les services de
suivi intensifs dans la communauté
dans le milieu c'est essentiellement une
approche d'équipe avec plusieurs
intervenants pour très peu de patients
presque 20 ans plus tard le docteur de
l'homme défend toujours fermement ce
modèle de suivi intensifs dans le milieu
il a lui-même été un des premiers
psychiatres al pratiquer sur le terrain
au Québec la littérature nous dit que le
modèle de suivi intensifs leur permet de
visiter moins souvent l'urgence d'être
hospitalisé moins souvent et d'être
hospitalisé moins longtemps
salut c'est Joanie ça va bien
oui c'est juste pour te dire que je
serai chez toi dans 5-10 minutes
ces équipes de suivi intensifs sont
composées de différents intervenants qui
se rendent directement chez les gens
souffrant de troubles mentaux sévères et
persistants
certains sont visités chaque jour ou
même plusieurs fois par jour ce sont des
gens vulnérables parfois judiciarisés et
qui peuvent être imprévisibles là tu
m'as dit que c'est un petit peu
difficile la solitude est-ce que tu vois
encore ton ami elle sent ouais comment
tu t'es débrouillé pour l'épicerie la
petite éternité
encore
qui est-ce que
tu aimerais qu'on regarde pour un
dépannage alimentaire dans ton quartier
enfin qu'on pourrait peut-être planifier
ça pour la semaine prochaine
si son suivi à tous les jours il y a au
moins de risques de décompenser
et au moins de risques de cesser leur
médication ils ont moins de risques de
devenir choix victime de violence ou
violent humaine nous avons appuyé le
développement d'un réseau pendant ces 15
années comme directeur national de la
santé mentale le docteur Delorme a fait
grimper considérablement le nombre
d'équipes de suivi intensifs dans le
milieu on devrait voir la personne très
rapidement mais le psychiatre a quitté
son poste en 2019 peu après l'élection
de la CAQ
selon lui le gouvernement nouvellement
élu ne lui donnait plus le pouvoir
nécessaire pour atteindre son objectif
qui était d'étendre le suivi intensif
dans le milieu à tous ceux qui en ont
besoin
[Musique]
de la population qui a une maladie
sévère comme la schizophrénie il y a à
peu près 10% de ces personnes-là qui ont
besoin de suivi l'intensif les normes
scientifiques là c'est une équipe par
100 000 de population
donc si j'ai un bassin de 100000 autour
de Granby j'ai besoin d'une équipe si
j'ai deux millions de population à
Montréal j'ai besoin de 20 équipes c'est
aussi simple que ça
donc depuis que le docteur Delorme est
parti le nombre d'équipes de suivi
intensifs dans le milieu hospit au
Québec il en manque encore
[Musique]
si on décortique il manque une dans la
capitale nationale
dans les Laurentides
une autre
à Laval
une équipe
en montée régie
[Musique]
et c'est à Montréal que la situation est
plus préoccupante il manque encore 10
équipes de suivi intensifs dans le
milieu ça veut dire que il y a 1000
personnes qui vivent à Montréal
peut-être un appartement peut-être à
répétition à l'hôpital ou peut-être dans
la rue qui bénéficierait d'avoir ce
service là mais qu'il l'emporte parce
que il manque 10 équipes non seulement
il manque d'équipe mais on découvre que
celles qui sont en place semblent moins
efficace depuis la fermeture du Centre
national d'excellence en santé mentale
annoncée en 2021
c'était un groupe d'experts mis sur pied
par André Delorme qui avait le mandat
entre autres de superviser les équipes
sur le terrain
on a perdu un expertise par les
conseillers qui ne sont plus là puis on
a perdu un accompagnement sur le terrain
alors si j'ai plus de conseiller j'ai
plus de sensationnel c'est pas le nom
qui fait la fonction c'est les
conseillers qui ont l'expertise clinique
requise alors moi je trouve ça
préoccupant
c'est le ministre responsable des
services sociaux Lionel karma qui a
défendu la décision à l'époque de fermer
le centre national il promettait que la
quinzaine d'experts du centre allait
continuer à faire le même travail au
sein du ministère de la santé mais la
moitié a quitté selon nos informations
le ministre a refusé de répondre à nos
questions et nous a référé à l'actuel
directeur national de la santé mentale
le psychiatre Pierre blot qui n'a pas
été en mesure de nous accorder une
entrevue
[Musique]
[Rires]
d'un côté on Martel qu'il faut combattre
la stigmatisation et on incite les gens
à demander de l'aide on vise surtout les
maladies les plus courantes comme
l'anxiété et la dépression ça arrive de
se sentir tout croche parler c'est
commencer à aller mieux
mais d'un autre côté on constate que les
préjugés persistent face aux troubles de
santé mentale plus lourd comme l'été
dernier lorsque le principal suspect des
trois meurtres commis en 24 heures à
Montréal Abdullah chahid a été abattu
par les policiers
[Musique]
je content qu'on est
qu'on soit débarrassé de cette individu
là j'ai été outré d'entendre un premier
ministre dire je suis content qu'on se
soit débarrassé de lui et puis je me
suis dit c'est pas vrai que un élu un
homme d'État peut se permettre de
bafouer aussi facilement des principes
juridiques fondamentaux vous avez deux
fils monsieur Lego imaginez-vous que
c'est un de vos fils qui a vécu ce que
nos garçons vivent puis que vous avez
failli les perdre parce que le système
de santé puis le système judiciaire a
pas été capable de les protéger qui sont
passés en des mains du filet
accepteriez-vous ça monsieur le
un mois après avoir été libéré par la
Commission d'examen des troubles mentaux
Joshua qui est en crise et ramené à
l'hôpital par les policiers peu après la
Commission le libère de nouveau sous
certaines conditions cette fois mais
Joshua ne se présente pas ses
rendez-vous et son psychiatre perd sa
trace en peu de temps je sois est passé
de premier de classe sportif à sans-abri
psychotique et violent
Joshua se souvient avoir tabassé un
inconnu pendant plus de deux mois il
multiplie les délits jusqu'à ce que les
policiers l'attrapent en septembre 2019
il ramène à l'hôpital Joshua sur lui des
cartes de crédit volé un couteau et un
pistolet à air comprimé
il faut quelque chose de grave arrive
pour qu'on puisse enfin prendre soin de
lui c'est comme si le système voulait
les criminaliser pour que c'est plus
simple et s'il est en prison c'est fini
on en parle plus
c'est ce qui est arrivé à Joshua en 2019
alors que ça fait environ trois ans que
ses parents se battent pour le faire
soigner il est enfin sur le point de
recevoir la médication qui va permettre
de le stabiliser et en plein délire
psychotique il poignarde son psychiatre
Joshua est accusé de tentative de
meurtre plutôt que de le garder à
l'hôpital on l'emmène en prison
après la pause Une vérité qui dérange de
la bouche d'une psychiatre émérite
des fois on donne des congés puis on est
on est inquiet
[Musique]
dans l'histoire de Joshua et d'autres
cas qu'on évoquait la consommation de
drogue et les troubles de santé mentale
étaient indissociables du passage à
l'acte violent et ça les experts nous
disent que c'est de plus en plus le cas
et que ça rend leur passion très
imprévisibles
[Musique]
un jeune homme qui poignarde son
psychiatre à l'hôpital trois personnes
tuées au hasard dans les rues de
Montréal en plein été et un suspect qui
était connu des services psychiatriques
sans compter tous les autres drames qui
soulèvent toujours la même question
comment on aurait pu les éviter on
efface un système lourd et très complexe
ces rangs qu'on a une personne qui est
non criminellement responsable qui a pas
un passé délinquant il faut que le
juridique et que le médical travaille
ensemble
vendredi matin il y a des gestionnaires
qui disent combien de conduite va donner
aujourd'hui
des fois on donne des congés puis on est
on est inquiet
si il y a quelque part on n'est pas
capable d'avoir un travail concerté
sécurité publique santé mentale on peut
se poser des questions sur est-ce qu'on
en a pas d'autres situations comme les
dépensé le bateau est percé différents
endroits l'eau monte
tous s'entendre pour dire que le système
peut faire mieux et ça fait longtemps
qu'on dit que les proches font partie de
la solution qu'ils doivent être plus
écoutés plus impliqués
[Musique]
il a fallu un événement grave touchant
touchant une personne qui méritait pas
ça au contraire une personne qui
cherchait à l'aider puis là on passe de
cette personne là est malade a pas eu
soin tu t'en vas en prison tu risques
d'y penser tes jours pendant des années
on a
supporté Joshua malgré tout ce qui s'est
passé
on demandant de l'aide au système pour
qu'il soit traité il était malade OK
personne n'a pas nous en préoccuper
[Applaudissements]
pas assez de monde qui se révoltent
comme les malades mentaux ne réclame pas
de meilleur traitements de plus de suivi
on les laisse aller c'est qu'on vit dans
une société de droit on est tellement
mal des sur les droits les droits mais
c'est parce qu'il doit les droits se
faire soigner sont là aussi puis les
droits d'avoir les soins requis où on en
requis depuis de pas attendre que la
personne tombe dans la BIM ou qu'à
commettre un geste irréparable c'est
droit là on en fait quoi on perd
confiance envers le système puis on se
sent tellement impuissant tu dis voyons
ça a pas de lutte on a une charte des
droits et liberté québécoise une charte
des droits et liberté canadienne on a
des droits fondamentaux qui semblent
important pour nos sociétés et dans les
sociétés occidentales comme la nôtre les
droits de l'individu ont précédé sur les
droits de la collectivité
on Ontario les lois sur la
confidentialité sont un peu différentes
et nous permettent ce qui s'appelle en
anglais sur call of care donc ça fait
qu'on a une application des proches
beaucoup plus
facilitante étant donné qu'ils peuvent
communiquer avec nous et nous on peut
communiquer avec eux pour prévenir des
rechutes et lever le drapeau lever le
flag comme on dit quand on voit des
signes précurseurs avant même qu'il y a
une crise donc on est beaucoup plus en
mode prévention qu'en mode réactif
et le risque de violence augmente quand
il manque d'équipe de suivi intensifs
dans le milieu pour suivre tous les cas
les plus lourds de maladies mentales
[Musique]
années il s'est faite des choses mais il
faut qu'on continue
c'est sûr qu'il va toujours y en avoir
qui vont des rapides mais plus le suivi
va être étroit plus ça va être une
réussite à long terme pour la société
ce que je peux rentrer
[Musique]
à diminuer un certain risque de récidive
pour ses patients fais attention à toi
on se revoit la semaine prochaine
[Musique]
d'après une étude le taux de récidive de
crime violent et d'environ 9% chez les
gens qui sont reconnus non
criminellement responsables pour cause
de troubles mentaux on a retracé les
dossiers des cinq individus présentés à
en jeu en 2006 qui avait commis des
agressions ou des meurtres pour lesquels
ils ont été déclarés non criminellement
responsables sur les cinq trois ont
récidivé depuis un pour tentative
d'évasion un autre pour introduction par
effraction et le troisième pour
agression armée
la seule façon qu'on pourrait avoir un
risque zéro c'est que si tous les
patients qui ont été auteurs de crimes
auteur de violence restez à l'hôpital et
qui avait aucun privilège de sortie donc
la seule façon d'avoir un risque zéro
serait de diminuer ce pôle de droit des
patients-là et qu'on aurait des milliers
ce sont des dizaines de milliers de
patients qui seraient techniquement
incarcéré dans des hôpitaux
psychiatriques
quand je choisis en prison il a passé
des mois dans sa cellule sans recevoir
de médicaments malgré une ordonnance de
traitement à son dossier il aura fallu
que ses parents se battent pour la faire
respecter
on a essayé de faire comprendre à qui
qui voulait nous entendre aux avocats au
système qui s'était pas sa place il est
malade personne voulait nous entendre
c'est pas nous mais ça doit être la
justice c'est pas la justice ça doit
être l'hôpital c'est pas l'hôpital ça va
être les suces
à répétition puis nous on se perdait
dans ce dédale
[Musique]
des histoires de résilience de patients
qui passent par le système de non-croman
responsable le système NCR puis qui s'en
sort puis qui réintègre la communauté il
y en a plein des histoires comme les
tiennes des belles histoires de
résilience
[Musique]
près d'un an que je suis à quitté
l'hôpital et il est de retour à la
maison avec sa famille il a repris ses
études et il travaille
[Musique]
n'importe quelle famille n'importe
quelle circonstance tu peux être riche
tu peux être pauvre tu peux être bien
entouré mal entouré tu peux avoir un bon
job en mauvais job ça peut affecter
n'importe qui les gens doivent
comprendre
un peu fou
est-ce que vous avez encore confiance au
citant moi je dirais que pas vraiment
parce que l'écran de Joshua comme on
vient de le raconter ça relève d'un
miracle
même si Joshua va mieux il est conscient
que tout n'est pas gagné il n'est pas
encore totalement libre il a plusieurs
conditions à respecter
Joshua doit notamment se présenter tous
les mois l'Institut Philippe Pinel pour
rencontrer son psychiatre et recevoir sa
médication et ce printemps Joshua doit
retourner devant la Commission d'examen
des troubles mentaux qui va analyser son
dossier pour s'assurer qu'il ne
représente pas un danger pour la
sécurité du public
[Musique]
j'espère que vous avez apprécié notre
reportage au nom de toute l'équipe merci
beaucoup d'avoir été là je vous donne
rendez-vous la semaine prochaine pour
une autre enquête
[Musique]